so I've missed so our last speaker today
is Robert King
he was already sort of announced in
surveys talk and okay go ahead
okay so first them I'd like to thank the
organizers for making this happen and
also for allowing me to speak here so
this is John survey
bravi Alexander clay and Eugene tang and
there's quite a bit of overlap with
survey already set but in this talk I
will focus on limitations so this is
sort of AB negative results instead of
constructive positive results and okay
so let me start at the beginning so of
course I'm very typically interested in
physics in finding ground state energies
and this is difficult because we have to
be very if over an exponentially large
Hilbert space so the standard approach
is usually to do some restricted set of
states that can be efficiently
represented and then we just minimize
over this subset of states so there are
two natural questions that we should ask
here the first one is better we can
actually approach this ounce of energy
and the second one is perhaps whether we
can do this efficiently I will focus on
the first question in this talk so so in
this alcohol restrict attention to
classical diagonal Hamiltonians and
variational families of states specified
by quantum circuits including in
particular the qa8 circuits okay so so
what are we trying to do we are trying
to maximize a function on the boolean
hypercube and the example that we're
focusing on is max color problem this on
some graph this fixes for if you
introduce binary variables for every
vertex now
as you well know computing the maximum
is np-hard so instead what we're aiming
for is basically an approximation
algorithm and we measure its quality in
terms of the approximation ratio which
is sort of the expected value of this
cost function compared to the maximum
now the most famous and really beautiful
algorithm that's known for this purpose
is the Givens Williamson algorithm which
is based on randomized rounding of an
SDP relaxation and it achieves this
approximation ratio of 0.8 7/8 for every
graph G so this is sort of in the worst
case and this is really remarkable
because there's good evidence to believe
that in fact this is among if pink that
is polynomial time algorithm algorithms
so if you assume the unique games
conjecture then there cannot be any
better algorithm in the worst case so in
the classical case we have something
very precise to compare to and this is
sort of the number we would like to
compete with in the quantum case okay so
so in the common case we can use this
key way away algorithm by far he goes on
cut moon and as surveyor already
explained them basically you start by
preparing a certain state and then you
measure in the computational basis to
get a bit string so of course I have to
specify what these states are and they
are defined in terms of these two
Hamiltonians so long it's a problem
Hamiltonian which encodes this cost
function and the other one is this
transverse field M Hamiltonian and now
we just alternate evolution and between
these two Hamiltonian story with the
whole plus state so a level PQ way or a
state is defined in terms of 2p
variational parameters beta and gamma
and it takes this form here now I should
probably remark that of course ve is a
sum of single cubed terms so you get as
cubed unitary sweni exponential and for
cost functions such as Mexico on a
bounded degree graph and C is also going
to be a sum of local tourism this means
that you actually get a nice quantum
circuit also for is Hamiltonian part now
what is important for the following is
this level P so I should tell you a few
things about the truths all say we would
like to choose a large level P to have a
large descriptive power means to get
close to this maximum energy but at the
same time increasing P means that we
have to and we have more variation
parameters in this mixed energy
maximization order and and perhaps the
most important reason to consider small
p is the fact that large P requires deep
circuits and for for miscue circuits we
would like to consider constant P or at
least some small values of P okay so
this is basically the question we would
like to press here can we eat this
Kevin's feelings were written for max
cut using constant level Q away and the
basic theme of the song is lower bounds
on circuits preparing certain States and
in particular symmetric unitary circuits
so let me define symmetry the symmetry
that you're interested in is Z to
symmetry so we have the symmetry
operator which is poly X on every cubed
and we say that the Hamiltonian is Z to
symmetric if it commutes with this
symmetry operator in our examples now we
can also define a state to be easy to
symmetric if it's an eigenstate of
is symmetry operator an example is the
GHC state given here on this product
sight of all plus and finally we will
color unitary z2 symmetric if it
commutes with the symmetry operator and
why is this concept relevant well it
turns out that the QA oh eight circuit
is actually easy to symmetric and the
initial state is also C two symmetric so
this is the case whenever the cost
function has the property that it is
invariant under flipping all the bits
and this is the case for max cut for
example so then this Hamiltonian or easy
to symmetric and this one C two
symmetric anyway so this means that we
take you away you can only create Z two
symmetric States and this is the
restriction that we would like to study
okay so let me begin with the simple
examples so this is basically the Ising
model on a ring and I will be uses the
following conventions throughout this
talk so consider families of
Hamiltonians index by the number of
qubits and these hamiltonians are sums
of local terms on some breadth and each
of these local terms has constant norm
and will normalize the energy in such a
way that the ground state energy is zero
so this is going to be important because
we would like to talk about low energy
states okay so what can we say about
preparing ground states of this
hamiltonian and in particular and what
is sort of the required nonlocality
of a circuits the dusties so let's look
at one the local circuits it should look
something like this and we can define
the range of the circuits as basically
the distance by which a local operator
can propagate under the action of the
circuit or its inverse so basically
they're talking about the sizes of the
forward
backward icons so this is just when one
way of quantifying locality in a circuit
of course you could also use geometric
notions in circle cuts okay so so what's
the answer to this question well it
depends on whether this unitary is
arbitrary order or whether being posed
that it is Z to symmetric so if the
unitary can be arbitrary then we can
prepare basically any ground state here
and we can achieve this just by applying
a llamar to every qubit strictly local
square it on the other hand if we demand
that U is Z to symmetry then you see
that this resulting state is an
eigenstate of the symmetry operator with
eigenvalue 1 so it has to be the GHS
state if it's in the ground space and we
know that preparing the GSS ID from a
product state needs linear range and so
if you see a quite quite a difference
between Z two symmetric circuits and
standard or arbitrary circuits so let me
briefly explain this range lower bound
so this can be found in this paper by
probably Hastings and / shredded and
it's really quite simple elegant
argument suppose we have a circuit which
repairs is th that state then we can
consider these Tuesday's from which is
the dear self say these states have the
property that they are orthogonal to
each other and if you trace out one of
the qubits then the reduced density
operators are the same so this means you
cannot distinguish them locally you need
at least and you look stupid you need to
look at thank you bills now if you apply
the inverse of the circuit we obtain a
product set in the first case and then
we obtain a state which is two
orthogonal to this product state so this
means because you're orthogonal to a
product say there has to be a local term
one of the qubits that distinguishes
these two states okay and now we can
just go back and look at the operator
that you're in by conjugating and you
see that this operator has to
distinguish these two states but we know
they take
only distinguish if the support of this
operator is large and this gives you
this range lower out okay so I told you
that z2 symmetric circuit needed a
linear range and we can ask whether
whether this bound is tight so here's a
circuit which prepares the DHD State
from from this product site and you see
that each of these gates is in fact a Z
to Z matrix of the whole circuit is z2
symmetric and the range is basically n
over 2 so so this bound can be achieved
so so far I've told I've talked about
the ground state of this Ising model and
we saw that there's a big difference
between symmetric and arbitrary circuits
and of course this is something
extremely well known to physicists under
the name of symmetry protected faces so
if you impose symmetry and you basically
can get a refined symmetry
classification and this is extremely
successful ok so let me now drop
symmetry for a moment and talk about a
different system where we talk and where
we think about sort of circuit depth
before continuing and so and so this was
about ground States we can ask whether
the same is true for low energy state
whether it's hard to create low energy
states in terms of range so we can
actually show a range lower bound for
pairing states that have low energy
density so if you want to get an energy
density below some epsilon then the
range has to scale as 1 over Epsilon and
basically you would like to get balance
of this type but for other models and
balance of scale somehow with n so this
is going to be our call but now I would
like to change the topic somewhat then
and drop the symmetry condition so let's
look at the
taury cult so this is a model where you
know that creating this is from a
product set requires a circuit depth
which is linear in the linear system
size so if you want to create a ground
state you need you need large depth and
this is a manifestation or a statement
of the facts that these grand said are
trances are topologically ordered a
different way of expressing this would
be to say that if you have a short depth
circuits then the output circuit the
output cannot be a ground state so
whenever the number of qubits is large
compared to the circuit depth you get an
output which is not a ground state of
the Tauri color so every zero in every
state if this model has topological
order and the natural question is
whether perhaps all low energy states
also have this property so by low energy
states
I mean states have have an energy
density below some constant and this
turns out to be not the case so for any
constant energy density you can actually
write down the circuit which has
constant depth and which creates a state
that has energy density below epsilon
times the number of qubits the way you
do this is you just create small surface
codes on small patches and then the only
energy contributions are from these
boundaries and this is low but intensity
so that the contribution can be made
arbitrarily small in terms of energy
density okay so this motivates a problem
and so we can ask whether they are
perhaps ten points for which not only
the ground states with all low energy
states are have topological order and
this is this was introduced by Friedman
and Hastings and it's called the no Low
Energy trivial states
conjecture so the conjecture is that
there are Hamiltonians
which have the this property here so
this property here says that as long as
the system size is large enough compared
to the circuit depth any circuit of that
depth cannot create a stated energy
density below some Epsilon so in other
words every low energy state is
non-trivial in the sense of circuit
depth for operation okay and the
conjecture says the research family of
local hamiltonians and so this
conjecture is of course very interesting
from the point of view of the
topological order but it's also
important for example and because of the
quantum PC PC era it's actually a
necessary condition for the compton PCP
theorem to hold some practices in easier
target to try to achieve first now it
turns out that many natural hamiltonians
they don't exhibit this nlts property as
I just explained Oracle Hamiltonians
don't have this property we can create
low energy states and other the various
other families of hamilton's that have
been shown not to exhibit this nlts
property there is also some positive
results so heroin in Eldar and also
Freedman in hastings did a show sort of
related properties this is a slightly
different property is no low energy
trivial state property and Freedman and
Hastings they restrict to certain
subsets of states so why am i explaining
all this well what we can do here is we
can create we can establish a cemetery
protected version of this conjecture so
basically we introduce something we call
the non low energy Z to trivial States
property or NL z to yes if you like and
the only difference here is that being
policy choosing
three everywhere so we asked these
Hamiltonians rz2 symmetry and the
unitary star now restricted to be easy
to symmetric and so the same and is that
you cannot create a low energy density
state using a c2 symmetric circuit of
small pets and our main result is
basically an explicit family of
Hamiltonians that have this ml z to TS
property okay so I mean describe the
construction so we need an expander
grass so basically infinite families of
graphs and where the trigger constant of
the graphs is lower bounded by some
constant independent of the number of
vertices
so the chika constant basically measures
how many edges are touched by a subset
of vertices and we can get such infinite
families and because they are so called
Ramanujam grass so they are gia regular
graphs which satisfy this lower bound on
the cheaper constant and their
constructions for any regularity
parameter larger than or equal to three
okay so let's take such a family of
Ramanujan graphs and just consider this
max cut Hamiltonian that I basically
introduced earlier and so if you look at
this I'm trying to turns out that they
satisfy this NL z to TS property so
whenever you have a circuit which has
small circuit tests as expressed by this
inequality then the resulting state has
an energy density lower bounded by this
constant times n so you cannot go below
this energy density using a short depth
circuit so unless your circuit depth is
growing at least rhythmically you cannot
create a lower energy state density says
okay so let me briefly explain the proof
of this result so suppose you you can
actually create such a low energy energy
density state then what you can do is
you can consider the distribution that
you get when you measure such a state in
the computational basis and because the
Hamiltonian is diagonal this
distribution is basically concentrated
on classical configurations that have
low energy so let me define the set of
low energy classical configurations as
those that have expectation value less
than H over 3 times N and then you know
from this inequality here that basically
this set of configurations has to have
at least constant weight at least weight
1/2 under the sample distribution of
this circuit ok so now we can ask what
do these low-energy
configurations look like and the point
here is that this expectation values
they are exactly given by a cot size
between the vertices labeled zero and
the vertices labeled 1 so this is
exactly because we defined this
Hamiltonian in this way so when this
number is small and it tells us
something about these cut sizes but for
expander graphs this cut size is lower
bounded by the jjigae constant times the
minimum size of these two sets okay so
now so for this low-energy column
configurations we have an upper bound of
this quantity so we get an upper bound
on basically the number of zeros in this
classical configuration and the number
of ones in this classical configuration
so in other words every low energy
configuration either has a small number
of ones or a large number of ones by
small and large I mean
less than an hour three or more than two
n over three so this denotes the Hamming
weight okay so going back I told you
that this set has large probability mass
under each addition produced by the
circuit so we know that the union of
these sets has probability mass at least
half and now we can use the fact that
our circuit is actually easy to
symmetric so this means that the output
distribution is invariant under flipping
all bits which means that this low
weight strings low hemingway eight
strings and high web hemming right
strings they have to have the same
probability mass so each of these sets
has to have at least a quarter
probability mass so now what this is
saying is that we have a depth D circuit
which produces a distribution that is
supported as large support or large
weight both on low weight strings and
high rate strings so these two sets have
high having this interlinear hamming
distance and this turned out to be
impossible unless the circuit that is
larger grows at least logarithmically
with n by a beautiful results by Eldora
and Herold
so this result is actually takes this
form so this is a corollary 43 in the
paper basically what it says is that if
you have a circuit which produces some
distribution and let's say we have a
lower bound on the probative rate of two
subsets that have some Hamming distance
so in our case is having these things is
linear then we have a relationship
between the depth of the circuit and
this distance particular if this
distance is large then it means that the
EPS also has to be large and this is
basically the origin of out of this
results and now I would like to go back
to Q way away and see what this implies
so of course if you let the level bro
arbitrarily then you can reach any
approximation ratio because this
approximates anybody computation but as
I said we were interested in small P or
constant V so for example for P equals 1
and G regular graphs there was is this
explicit formula for the approximation
approximation ratio achieved by QA way
and as we already mentioned Hastings
found that numerically optimized
classical algorithms are actually better
in terms of approximation ratio for for
for graphs with regularity parameter up
to 1000 so with just a few exceptions
these classical algorithms are actually
better than level 1 you are way now in
the very first paper and about a QA way
there was also a computation of the
approximation ratio for level 2 q AO a
for certain grass and while also this
number is of course am not quite as high
as this humans williamson result but
what we really care about now is and
whether we can perhaps in crispy and and
get something better so what about M
contains P that is larger than one or
two preps can we say something here
well this NL z to TS property can be
immediately translated to this to this
problem and we can get an upper bound on
the QA approximation ratio for the
irregular grass so we will be choosing
particular families of irregular
bipartite graphs so as long as the level
the QIO a level is less than logarithmic
you cannot beat this number this
approximate
generation in particular if you choose
is the large enough then this have
become smaller than this commence
Williamson approximation ratio so in
other words for any constant P certainly
satisfies this you cannot beat Kevin
Williamson using QA QA away in for for
this particular set of reps okay so the
proof of this is actually really maybe
immediate consequence of what I said
before one thing I would like to point
out here is that we use bipartite graphs
because then we know what this maximum
is that this makes makes it easy to
compute approximation ratios and then we
also use Viper tightness to to a certain
symmetry argument which basically allows
you to change the sign in some sense
okay and then then you can really relate
these two to this NL z to TS which can
be stated in this form and the only
ingredient you need at this point is
that if you have a QA away a circuit
then it's e to a symmetric of course and
d well the depth is bounded by the level
x the regularity of the graph
so so this is basically our main results
so we cannot beat governments Williamson
for constant level P so now just to
conclude M so so we have this n of T s
property and of course in the general
properties you open we have this upper
bound on what Qi or you can do and I
should say that this is of
a worst case bound so this relates the
question that made on that earlier so we
don't three know whether perhaps
families where this continent really
does perform well and I think it's
interesting to ask question whether
perhaps we can say more about generic
instances and there was his recent paper
by at fari
Quebec and Guttman that was mentioned
earlier where they actually consider
random graphs and the problem of finding
large independent sets and then they
found some upper bound which has the
same forum so it also and says that this
level has to grow logarithmic ly if you
want to beat a certain threshold okay I
think this is an interesting direction
to consider sort of generic instances
and hardness for that and finally as we
saw in Turkish talk we can also ask
about ways of getting around this Nowell
theorem and using for example this
variable elimination idea so basically
this makes the algorithm non-local and
therefore these fans to multiply okay so
with this I would like to thank you and
my collaborators and we thank you
Roberts for her nice talk maybe I can
quickly ask a question before our people
say something so to what extent so
you're relying very much on the symmetry
right you could say how robust are these
results to deviations they're off for
example the in practice the QA is not
perfectly symmetric perhaps but then you
still you still prove something or is it
really you know is it not very robust
case that you're assuming that you has
this symmetry the z2 symmetry right I
mean
understand the question but I think
maybe it's a bit difficult to define
what approximate symmetry means but yeah
right I understand I mean that's of
course the restriction but on the other
hand it's slightly I mean it applies to
things that are more general way do you
think is result still holds if you I
mean what's your intuition if there's
still some from that form so well if you
would you know modify this you don't
fully impose the symmetry but it's
slightly were we haven't thought too
much about this I mean certainly if you
drop the symmetry all together then the
sizing model doesn't satisfy this
property anymore so may I say something
you know if you look at the art paper or
recent paper we look at independence sad
and independence that does not have the
g2 symmetry so you know we're able to
get similar results but the way we get
it is by looking at the light cone and
showing that if you have qubits which
are far apart on a graph that the
measurement outcomes are uncorrelated
and we don't do using any symmetry
property so yeah you can't Barbara okay
I see yeah there may be more general
arguments yes I mean it's the same
spirit but you know it depends yeah you
don't need to see to independence that
doesn't happen to symmetry okay so we
can have some other questions I have a
couple of small questions first a kind
of well more physics oriented question
this property nlts is it expected to
mean something for the you know high
robustness of topological order or
something like that so I guess you mean
something like non zero temperature
perhaps yes exactly right
also I think I think they were yeah
there is a paper by Eldar about sort of
thermal fades keeps eights and nlts like
questions but I'm not sure how directly
and this relates to low lighting
excitations okay I wonder their small
question about the heuristics of this GW
you know there's this threshold or this
guaranteed number point eight seven
eight that you're always above but is
there some expectation that for most
graphs it's far above that or much
closer to one
I mean I'm not familiar with this I mean
it's a worst case bound there's no
nothing that you know about concerning
like typical case okay and Robert like
you said like you have these open
questions about other symmetries do you
have any comments on that
how about other symmetries yes so so one
question would be for example XIII
symmetry which we will need for this
colouring problems that's our dimensions
so there I mean this is still an open or
working progress I guess symmetry group
but but we think that the techniques
that you that you use could be extended
to this other symmetries or everything
that there there's some barrier there I
think the difficulties finding sort of
the right kind of examples so I assume
some related ideas should apply that
it's not immediate or at least it
doesn't seem to be medians from from our
results I think it would be nice to have
some general approach that gives you
this kind of bounce more generally for
for different kinds of problems at the
same time thanks more questions I have
to see one question from the audience
Karen moans asks so to confirm the best
classical poly time algorithm beats Q
AOA for any constant level P only on the
irregular bipartite graphs right not in
general well in fact it's it's more
specific than that I mean it's a certain
family
do you regular bipartite graphs namely
those that have said or expand regress
and you need this expansion balance
great other questions maybe a last one
maybe not okay anyhow let's thank Robert
again and we're closing this session
okay see you all tomorrow tomorrow